good evening everybody my name is Hannah
K and I'm the executive producer at
intelligence Squad a very warm welcome
to all of you here at St Martin's in the
field in London and all of you watching
on the live stream wherever you are in
the world I hope we'll be getting some
good questions from you later on in the
Q&A and tonight we are hugely honored to
welcome Nick Cave and sha o o'hagen to
this wonderful space Nick of course is
the songwriter and lead singer of Nick
Cave and the bad seeds and in recent
years he's been engaging more with his
fans especially through his website the
redand files where each week he answers
a letter from amongst all the many that
are sent in sha is an award-winning
journalist and he's a freelance writer
on arts and culture for the Observer the
two of of them have known each other for
over 20 years and it was back in deepest
lockdown in 2020 when they started a
series of recorded conversations that
were transcribed and published in into a
book called faith hope and Carnage and
it offers a glimpse into Nick's inner
world and touches on love grief loss and
religion and they're here with us
tonight to carry on the conversation but
now please give a very warm welcome to
Nick Cave and sha
o'hagen thank you
hello some familiar faces in the front
row follow us around everywhere um thank
you all for coming
um before we start we just um agreed we
should the the event is somewhat shaded
by sadness tonight because of the news
of the death of Shan McAn who is a close
friend to both of us and um it's very
upsetting news um in fact the first time
that you met Shane was when I brought
him to that Infamous interview in 198 n
for the enemy and it's they've had a
very very strong friendship and
relationship ever since yeah so um it's
it's a great genius as we all know I
mean you can talk about his songwriting
better than I can but um a sad day yeah
it's a very sad day today we knew he was
ill for a long time but um and you
prepare for these sorts of things but it
was a shock it's a shock and uh
um you know the world's lost some a
great artist I think yeah yeah and a
great human being in some sorry and a
great human very echoey here it's
incredibly echoey um um but say that
again and a great human being yeah I
mean there was something I don't know if
people
know you know his his reputation
precedes him in a way but Shane was an
incredibly kind
um sort of
generous uh pure Spirit um and just an
extraordinary person a extremely funny
guy uh and just I in my my view at
least
uh the songwriter of his
generation I don't know too much about
Irish music you probably know a lot more
about it than I do but I would say he's
you know sitting up there oh for sure
you know within the whole historical
context as one of the great songwriters
yeah Irish songwriters and greatest
great songwriters per se I think there
there's a sort of raw honesty to his
work that I've never found anywhere else
really yeah he he always had something
that I didn't quite understand back then
um when I first met him was a genuine
compassion towards people you know he
just he was just kind to people even
though he was costic and sort of uh had
this uh rough Edge to him he was
enormously generous and kind to Ordinary
People oh for sure yeah um you know
and just an extraordinary guy I'm just
it's just very sad today yeah yeah I
have one story I I just you've reminded
me of a story when and I I got a call
from him once um and the poges were I
think number two in the charts with
fairy tale and he said oh come and meet
me in King's cross before it was
gentrified come and meet me in the Wimpy
bar in King's cross we we were living
the dream in those days and I remember I
turned up and he was always an hour late
but I suddenly noticed this commotion
and there was two guys who I thought
were homeless scrabbling about on the
side of the road and one of them was
Shan and he' basically given money to a
homeless person and the notes had blown
away and the both of them were running
around trying to and I remember thinking
like I can't imagine the pet shop
by scrabbling around in the gutter on
King's cross but it said something about
his sort of yeah authenticity I saw that
a lot with him yeah he had he would
carry around a big roll of cash that he
would just give to to give to people
essentially yeah andway a beautiful
person and um he'll be he'll be greatly
missed I think yeah yeah we should go in
we're here ostensibly still a year we're
still plugging this year on this life
the old dog yet um to talk about all the
sort of themes that come up in the book
um but we're also going to talk about
music which Nick is often reluctant to
do because um I think you finished
mixing an album a bad SE album yesterday
we it it it it came back mastered today
so that means I don't know if you know
what that means but uh you mix you mix
the record you make the record no you
write the record yeah no you get asked
by your manager to make a record so you
write the record and then you take it
into the studio and record the record
and then you take it to someone and mix
the record and then you send it off and
someone Masters the record and that
means it's ready to
be uh released into the world and it
sounds [__]
awesome I mean
this I'm just
saying um it it's been extraordinarily
difficult record to make for some reason
um I always sort of I remember Lou Reed
saying something about after a while you
understand that the next record will
come and things just get easier here uh
I've not found that to be the case no at
all and each record just becomes more
difficult to arrive at
that at that place and uh This Record
was extremely difficult but it's it's
you know it's really good that's not the
feeling I got from you over the last few
months you felt it felt very positive
and maybe you were on the last well i'
I'd finish writing it i' finished it's
it's the lyric writing that's uh
extremely difficult for me
um you know because
uh I'm trying to say something with my
lyrics I'm not I'm not just trying to
collect a bunch of songs together I'm
trying to sort of find the thing that I
want to say and that's quite difficult
um record after record can you talk
about the thing you want to say on this
record no no can you talk about the
title of the no okay it's a great title
though
[__] it is the best title yet um it but
it is a bad seeds record as opposed to
yeah it's got It's got all the all the
bad seeds on it yeah and you've just got
back from Buffalo Upstate New York with
David that's right we we uh usually or
the way it's tended to be over the last
few records is that me and Warren uh
tend to mix the records um but this is a
very complex record and we sort of
finally come to a sort of of Latter-day
realization that we don't know what
we're doing in the studio uh and that we
need somebody else to do it so we took
it to Dave fredman who's who's uh just
he he used to be in Mercury rev and uh
he did all the Flaming Lips records and
which are really beautifully put
together those records and uh he mixed
it and did a you know amazing job so
while you hung out well yeah he he had
this weird uh he had this weird way
which was extraordinary for me and
Warren who are so a couple of complete
control freaks about everything he he
would say in the morning you you mix it
in like a Shack in the woods and in his
studio in Buffalo uh he said well what
do you want this this song I'm going to
mix this song today what do you want it
to sound like and you're like oh you
know it's you don't play the song He you
just sort of describe it to him like
that and he goes okay thank you and he
goes into the studio and he he locks the
door and doesn't allow us near the
record um and then at 3:00 he comes out
and says I have something to show to you
and uh and we you know would you care to
comment and we go in and listen to it
was just like [__] hell this is this
is amazing so we were really suspicious
about this process to begin with because
we didn't really know what this guy
could do but he was amazing and he
turned songs that
were um difficult sort of balancing axe
into into things that really beautiful
so he's done an amazing
job meanwhile you and Warren were
hanging out in the great w just sit in
the kitchen kind of in the Great Western
in Buffalo the Great Western Hotel in
Buffalo yeah stayed in the great the the
Best Western Best Western yeah Liv in a
dream one yeah two
stars in fact in fact there was I got
quite friendly with one of the cleaners
there and uh she she's on the next
record huh she's on the next record well
she she might be but she's she was this
this um wonderful woman and she she was
uh she the the people in the Best
Western were quite interesting and she
said so you're in a band I hear you
called the bad seeds and and why why are
why are you called the bad seeds and I
said well because we're evil and she
goes you're not evil I work at the Best
Western I've seen
evil I'm like
okay have a nice night okay yeah anyway
we stayed there and it was just an
amazing
experience and you recently finished uh
I was going to say a solo tour but it
was you and Colin from radio head and I
must say I saw it in New York and it was
quite
extraordinary the difference
between a solo piano concert by you and
this guy playing quite minimal base but
it such an extraordinary difference he
made to the songs yeah yeah you said
something like
um that kind of kept going through my
mind as as I did Future coner it's it
was so lovely to hear him play or you
could really hear him when you could
really hear it when he wasn't playing or
something like that which wasn't
entirely encouraging but um but it was
an incredible experience too I'm it's
I'm just got sort of Triumph exhaustion
or something at the moment so when you
just to go back to what you said when
you had this
realization what do you now think those
preoccupations are
well
uh I mean maybe this is clear to
everybody but it just wasn't clear to me
as such but the religious nature of the
songs was
just um it's funny cuz I the this priest
or Vicor came along to one of the shows
that I'd met in London and uh he he'd
never heard the band before he wanted to
he wanted to um come along and in
Minneapolis and I kept singing the songs
and just about every second song had
Jesus in it and I kept thinking [__]
this guy must think I'm sort of some
religious nut you know that they they
they were they were from the beginning
in a way religious songs there was that
and the the UN the the idea of loss um
was has always been there um so there
there was just a a lot of things that
themes that I feel that I've freshly
engaged in that I I've actually been
involved in from the start you know it's
hard for me to go back and look at some
of the early songs as having those
preoccupations they seem much Wilder and
yeah they they they are they they're
Wilder but they're they the int is
similar the sort of idea of
transcendence and um the attempt of
[Music]
bringing the audience together in some
way whether it whether it
was uh in love or sort of contempt or
whatever it was the same idea in some
kind of way it was an it
was some sort of attempt to sort of
shed this the the present day
preoccupations and move to something to
step into something else and we do that
in different sorts of ways but is it
ever difficult for you when you sit at
the piano that you're not doing you're
not engaging you're not out on the lip
of the stage you're not doing that yeah
it's a little little disconcerting
um because
I sort
of uh feed off the audience and feed off
the Expressions on people's faces and
the communal nature of the thing it
feels like a sort of circular thing and
I'm not really watching the audience as
I'm playing so it's different and I know
this record it's obviously a bad Sage
record as opposed to a Nick Cave of or
indeed a nick kave of Warren Ellis
record does it conform in any way to the
things that you talked about in here
like the improvisatory nature of music
yeah
that's still at the core of what you do
yeah it it is but I don't want to go
into too much about what the records
like but it's it's um just insanely
good okay hint the hint is
taken so in terms of the book it's I I
can't even remember how it's is it a
year it's over a year since it was
published it's it's um becoming a little
obscene now that we're still talking
about it and it's about two or 3 years
since we did it yeah so that's quite a
lot of time do you have you ever read it
the
book um I I actually haven't read it
since it came out I dipped into it but I
sort of go well you mean read it from
beginning to end I sit there and pour or
make notes I know no I I don't I don't
feel the urge to to to dip into it very
much sad to
say what about you I no
good do you listen to your own records
no
no um how do you except the last one cuz
it's so
good how do you
feel has your feelings towards it
changed in I mean I I do I do look I do
open it up sometimes and have a look and
I'm surprised by it and I like it um I
think it stands up um I'm interested to
see what I was thinking about back then
has now changed to some degree or or
things move on or um but the great the
thing I love about the book and I and
I'll be eternally grateful to you for is
is um engaging me in a conversation that
allowed me to sort of consolidate all
the sort of random thoughts that
were um just floating around in my head
about all manner of things in
conversation and I'd just never really
done that before you know we we sat down
and had a conversation about things that
I'd never talked about essentially I
mean I'd read I'd written things in the
red hand files and stuff but never
really um had any um push back or or
anyone uh pushing the pushing the
thoughts on and I love that about the
book that it
starts in one place and ends somewhere
else um much more interesting much more
deeper much more meaningful
through the process of uh conversation I
think I mean I've said this before but
the thing about this book for me is that
it is a testament to the value of the
the necessary value of
conversation why do you think that I
kind of know the answer to this but why
do you think that is so important right
now
um
because I mean you know this this is has
changed a little bit I think from when
we when we were talking about that in
the book but but I feel that certainly
at the time of talking about that I
thought um that the idea of conversation
was being looked at with
suspicion that um that the idea of an
open conversation was was starting to be
looked at as something that was
um
[Music]
um uh a kind of dangerous thing to do
and I just felt very strongly that that
wasn't the case and
that we need more speech rather than
less speech and I was very concerned
with that at the time I'm not so sure
I'm so concerned with that now I think
things are changing and people are kind
of
um you know growing a little tired of
um that but I've no I've no I mean the
the internet's flooded with podcasts
with people having you know open good
faith conversations and so forth so I
think that the tide is turned in that
respect but I think when we were writing
it it was there was still that feeling
of uh you needed to be careful about
what you talked about and yeah um you
have in the red hand files in the book
and in a lot of these
conversations become I hope I'm not
presuming too much here but you've
become more Adept at speaking and
articulating your loss your personal
loss with Arthur and even with Jethro
later though he wasn't sort of that
happened after the book is is
that has that happened through the
actual doing of it through the the fact
that you were given a sort of form or a
forum to to clarify your
thoughts yeah I just
found it's a funny thing to write about
loss
it's
um even though you're being open it's
it's also a kind of
obscuring mechanism to the way that you
actually feel um if you can sort of
write about it and talk about it and
articulated it keeps the actual feelings
weirdly at
Bay um I noticed and that there's um
deep sort
of chasms of of of grief that talking
doesn't really um
help um and so on some
level to keep talking is just to
hold the feelings and and this new world
at Bay in some way um so but I don't I
don't know what I I I don't really know
what I mean by that except that um
sometimes it's not the talking that is
is the thing that uh
eventually leads you out of the darkness
it's um
it's the the the humanness of people and
small acts of kindness and and practical
matters and you know I I I mean I don't
really maybe this is not the right you
know you
know you know Victoria rang me today
Shane's wife um you know and
uh I could just I could recognize that
uh situation she's in uh of thousands of
people coming around and
everyone everyone making demands on
her be because people are so upset and
it it really ultimately is the small
silent acts of kindness uh that you
barely see happen that are the that are
the things that um draw you out of
yourself you know I'm talking about
someone making you a cup of tea you know
and all the language that that I that I
am that I've grown quite good at talking
about is is a thing for another time
it's a thing
for
um something where you've you've gotten
Beyond where you can reflect that the
way I talk about it is is is is sort of
reflection I think you you you pushed me
in the book to talk about what actually
happened
and you you wanted me to talk about what
happened on the day that Arthur died
well well you were you were concerned
that I was talking forever from the
other side of the chasm let's say yeah
yeah um and that
was suddenly shockingly difficult um and
I realized that I'd never
actually for all the language I'd
actually never really talked about those
things so do you regret that no no I
don't regret it
but
um difficult stuff yeah it was it was
something to hear Victoria today it
really it really
um brought it you know it was yeah take
you back there yeah yeah I mean you hear
about these things and they hit you but
they don't hit you
and talking talking to Victoria it
really hit me that Shaina died because
uh he was sort of reflected by through
her her her feelings you know
yeah and loss is is kind of embedded in
this book the idea of it and recently
you you did a I thought a quite amazing
podcast with a woman whose name that
gives me Christa tippet Christa tippet
yeah and you said there that you felt
now that loss was you can put this
better than me but it was the defining
condition of Our Lives is that correct
yeah I I I
think yeah that's personally how I see
the way we are as human beings um I
think
we're I I don't think the condition of
life is greed
or power or power yeah or tyranny or
these sorts of things I I don't think
that's what or or or oppression I don't
think these are the things that define
what we are as human beings um I sort of
reject those Notions and I think that
there is a commonness about us all that
is to do with
loss um and
and and I think that born into us it's
it's our condition of life that we're
bright things born into uh loss and uh I
don't mean that in a depressing way I I
mean loss very much not not just in
historical loss or our Collective loss
as a society or or our ultimate personal
loss and the loss of the people around
us um I
mean I don't mean that in a in a depress
in a depressing way I think that that un
that's understanding about things is
what gives our life substance and
meaning it's that fundamental
understanding that we
die um I don't agree with the concept of
the denial of death it's it's an
acceptance I think of of death that we
we have a fundamental understanding of
that whether we can talk about it or not
it's there in our blood and bones and
um and and these things that we do art
or religion or these sorts of things are
a kind of Celebration they're not
they're not a denial but rather a
celebration of of the meaning of what it
is to live uh in a in such a precarious
situation yeah and I I take it you don't
I think you've said this before but you
don't feel that the idea of closure or
or even acceptance is really a place as
as we as we understand it yeah I mean I
think as
um
uh Christ tippet yeah sorry remember
you're like
me two old trying to remember names um
she she uh you know I I objected to the
word closure and I think she she made a
comment that word had long being sort of
debunked as
a as a you know this idea of closure is
ridiculous is it not what people crave
for though well I don't I don't want
closure I I I I don't
even I didn't even look for acceptance
you know I just think it's a it's a
living part of what I am uh these losses
and the loss all the losses are a living
part of the fabric of what I am um it's
not something that I
can
uh you know
close have closure with and put over
there and then continue my life as it
was it's not it's it's not as it was Nor
nor should it be you
know could you have gotten through this
or or dealt with
it had you not had the religious aspect
of your life the Deep religious um
Dynamic that you
have it it I get quite nervous when you
say deep religious well it's certainly
deep um because it is it is deep and
it's religious but it doesn't mean what
that feels like it means um and that's
that's a sort of um a certainty about
these matters I I I know a lot of deeply
religious people and they're they're
fundamentally different they seem
fundamentally different than I am in
regard to religion um I feel very
conflicted in regard to religion but I
do feel that I I move or inch
towards um some kind of spiritual truth
I'm not there yet but it feels uh
fundamental
to the way I am and the journey that I'm
that I'm
on but you know it's
like you know it's it's not without its
deep skepticism and and doubt and you
know I thought and and and I
mean and this is something I don't is
often misunderstood too um I I I find
out how I misunderstood through the red
hand files because people send in
questions and they say well you know now
that you're a Christian or something
like that or or even worse now that
you're a Tory I keep getting and I'm
like what the [__] where did that come
from so you so you got that one from
me I mean I guess these things must I
don't go on social media but these ideas
must be coming from social media cuz
they're so stupid well well you you did
say I think
probably jokingly that you know to be a
conservative was the thing well I I I
used the word
conservative uh some time ago to talk
about a kind of a way of approaching the
world and that was immediately seen as
being a Tory and I I didn't I didn't
even that didn't even occur to me or or
so I I object to that and I just just
want to set the record straight I'm
[Laughter]
Yip oh
god oh he's Yip he's Yip yeah I just
seeing GM no I'm not um well L
really no but I mean I don't know where
we are in the conversation now but but
you're not a conservative and you're not
a Christian well well the the word the
word conservative for me
um has something to do we we have to
sort of uh look at it in a different way
and I was trying to just describe what I
felt the conservative temperament might
be and to me it has something to do with
the soul I know in your mind you you
couldn't imagine such a thing but it has
something to do with a depth of
understanding about our our society and
and and uh a kind of Ste a kind of
stewardship over the traditions of our
society in some kind of way and that
they have some intrinsic value uh that's
all that they're not uh they're not set
in stone uh but they are worth
protecting uh and and expanding so so
because I because the
conservative temperament has something
to with a kind of melancholy Soulful
feeling towards the world or an un or
fundamental understanding of loss in
that the things that we lose are it's
very easy to to lose things and very
hard to get them back uh and and so that
that's what I was really talking about
in in regard to a conservative nature
the fundamental desire to
cons conserve in some way uh the
collected wisdom of the world
and you know I don't think that makes me
a Tory no
um is that you or me that's that's God
is in the house and or Marx is in the
house um so so anyway I don't know why
why we're talking about that but we we
were talking about no I find it
interesting that
you you talk about well let's move on to
to God and Christianity you talk
about the traditionalism of Christianity
you you practice you you go to church
yeah if if someone calls you a Christian
you immediately recoil in horror well
that's because I recoil with horror when
someone says they're a Christian you
know someone comes up to me and goes hey
I'm a Christian I go you know I'm it
worries me it just I just I I react the
skeptic In Me Is the is the sort of Def
my default setting and and it always has
been and I have um part of uh my
interest in church and interest in the
sort of mystical nature of these sorts
of things is that uh Journey taken away
from the from that
skeptical uh
person that you know that default
setting that I have of Suspicion and
skepticism about these sorts of
things because I feel that when I do
move
away uh when I
shed that skepticism something happens
to me that is really
uh is a Transcendent thing it it happens
and and for me personally I find that in
a church I get that in a church I get
that within a Christian ceremony for
example
um because I because I always have as as
a as a child really
responded weirdly to the story of Christ
I'm not quite sure why um and it's that
narrative story that exists within the
Christian Rel religion that sort of
draws me to it in the way that I'm not
drawn to other religions I'm not really
drawn to the abstract nature of of god
let's say I feel uncomfortable to
sit it needs that human element and I
think that that's what um that interests
me about the Christian story it's
essentially a human story I guess yeah
it's a human story that I that I relate
to very strongly and and with and
different parts of that story uh through
different periods of my life I've always
felt um looking at it slightly detached
having had a religious
upbringing um it's hard to go back into
that but from in a detached way I always
think of faith is essentially private
yes but you say it's a communal thing
that you like Well it Well it's it is a
communal thing to be part of a of a
church service obviously um and there's
great benefits in that and I think
people get a lot out of that but I'm I'm
much the same as you it's a it's a
private matter um for me as
well and the the deepening of the fear I
talked to I mean what sorry
but what I've noticed happening we can
get off this subject soon yeah but what
what I have noticed happening is is uh
there is a movement towards Christianity
that I I'm that that disturbs me which
is a a
political a politically motivated
movement towards Christian Christianity
that I've
noticed
um amongst people that that feel like
it's they can use Christianity as some
sort of firewall or Bull bullwark
against the
current um cultural moment or
uh other fundamentalist religions or
whatever and and I I see Christianity
being used in that way and that that I I
don't
that I that's not my interest in
Christianity my interest in Christianity
is as you say entirely personal and and
emotional it's an
emotional um it's an emotional thing
yeah there's there's an interesting
thing in the book um well you talk about
the pressence of songs and that they can
almost foretell certain things before
they happen and I just listening to you
it seems like that preoccupation you've
always had with God and the songs all
kind of on a bigger level for told where
you were going for told your
journey say that again the the notion
that a single song for instance can be
pressed yes that's right yeah uh that
can be applied to the whole the
realization you had recently with Colin
that oh I see what you mean yeah yeah I
mean that's that's quite right I mean
it's
um it does it it was doing that you know
it's playing very old songs and they
felt very new to me they felt like they
were addressing exactly the the things
that were sort of preoccupying me um it
was quite a beautiful thing it's a it's
a very
beautiful um show to perform you
know and your work rate seems
quite I mean it's always been prodigious
but has it accelerated as you've got
older um it appears that way to me but
maybe it's it was always
this my plan is to sort of strip it back
or strip it down um because there's all
these extracurricular things that are
going on but the thing is the
more the more well-known you get the
more
interesting
the things that come in are you know
like the people want you to do or
collaborate with or get involved with
you know so it's it's hard it's hard to
is it hard to balance that reflective
life you talk about and the well exactly
this is this is the problem with touring
um it's very hard to have a it's it's
you're your life is eternally
interrupted by your creativity
actually um certainly
touring um
like yeah I find I'm always having to
sort of go back to the place I was at
before I went on tour going on tour is a
sort of spiritual thing in itself of
course it's a religious thing to to some
degree too but um I always feel like it
it sort of prevents any personal Forward
Motion how is it a religious
thing um I think it's it's for me it's
religious because of what it's trying to
do which is to collect a group of people
together and uh lift them lift them up
in uh strip them
of the sort of their
mundane
n for a moment and lift them up into
something that's communal and
um um moving toward um what could be
called God or whatever you want to call
that but moving towards something be
outside
oneself
all